and what do you do for the superball you
know what Sunday you old [ __ ] I'm glad
you asked I'm glad you asked I'll give
you three guesses or where I'm gonna be
now I could be on the field with my
friend Tariq Aziz me too so could you
have had several offers we could both be
down there I actually got offered to do
some stuff for the Super Bowl really
Papi's not flying down to Miami to do
that tough tough because we don't like
to fly it's just too much at the end of
the day plus I'm in Cleveland Thursday
to Sunday
now I'm gonna live in Ohio okay you're
in Ohio I'm at hilarities you're at
funny funny bone come on I'm only there
Friday Saturday
okay are you doing Sunday show and clean
I'm not oh they don't fly back on the
Sunday now would you shoot down to Miami
shoot down in Miami or I could shoot
somewhere else where were two words
where would you expect me to be in I
give you three guesses um well you give
me at the podcasts on Monday
it has him a trip you're obvious well I
guess 100 yeah are you going to San
Francisco yeah you talk no Denver yeah
we're I think celebrity New York thinks
celebrity yeah
Sundance is in a row now you [ __ ] son
of a [ __ ] if you need me I'll be at
sliced loans house hey you are a regular
geriatric Fox if I have to see another
post of all you again for every occasion
I'm gonna freak out that's that's
because of me you just I guess just get
some pages no just have fun with your
friends nope with the whole flavor town
to [ __ ] beat it
there's always a shot like this no dude
get back in the kitchen hey man he'd
already cooked up by hell of a storm we
have a right to be in a picture you son
of a [ __ ] it's good time god yes who
knows we'll be there Strahan I might be
talking football I got a lot of friends
now well stay and work in but yeah here
yeah he's the best
oh I don't have to hear about on Monday
yeah oh you just you'll read a better
social media
hopefully suppose your name Ronnie
hopefully it's not Brian Callaghan
anyway every fun though it's give me
your Super Ball oh yeah I'm excited
about it a lot of insiders think the
vanishing it their butts what is that
true yeah by my own
yes that's like don't salt in the home
case what what do you mean by that he
can do everything right and well in
other words I mean you can't force him
to pass in the pocket can't force him to
run and hit him on the outside I love
talking about your legs are uh they're
white huh pretty pale you know I got
Jesus some Sun and somehow they have
built-in sunblock the Sun they'll come
out right right yeah yeah yeah yeah
watch your tongue
oh good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]